[Music]
hello everyone
so we'll go we are going to continue our
discussion uh
in the same vein that we had been doing
in the previous part of the lecture
where we said that we are going to
orient our coordinate axis along the
principal directions
so uh so continuing along that same vein
what what we are going to do here is
that
we are going to consider a situation
where we have already
oriented our uh our coordinate axis
along the principal directions
so uh but
now we want to consider a special type
of plane
okay this plane mind you is not going to
be
any one of the three principal planes
rather it is going to be a special kind
of plane
uh which has uh the property
the special property that it is equally
inclined to all the three coordinate
axes
and please note now that now the
coordinate axis
are along the principle directions so
this plane that we are considering the
special new plane that we are
considering
that is going to be equally and inclined
to the principal directions
also okay so now you uh
you think what should be the unit
outward normal
to that plane to this special plane okay
so first of all what we are going to say
is that uh
the name of the topic is of course
octahedral stress but
uh we'll see in a moment what what is
the what is the purpose of this word
octahedral
uh so consider
let's write this in white so
consider a plane uh
so i think it's better to first write
down
that
[Music]
where the coordinate axes are oriented
along the
principal directions so we
have that out of probate
now under this situation where the
coordinate axes are oriented along the
principal directions
we consider a plane
which is equally inclined
to the coordinate access
or equivalently we can say
[Music]
to the principal directions
[Music]
all right now
what should be uh this is what is what i
was getting at
uh what should be the
the unit outward normal components b so
if you
consider the n hat the unit output
normal
of this plane okay of this plane
then we understand
that this should be like this
we have written this earlier
in the context of uh deriving our
framework for the principal
stresses so we understand this but
please note now that since
we have already chosen a situation where
the coordinate axis are
themselves oriented along the principle
directions therefore this e1
e2 and e3 they are oriented along the
principal directions
this you must remember now what we are
additionally saying is that
we are considering such a plane on which
the unit outward normal is the the n hat
that is what we are talking about now
this uh
this unit outward normal because the
plane itself is oriented or equally
inclined to the axis
the unit outward normal is also going to
have equal angles
with the uh uh
with the three uh axis with the three
coordinate axis
which means that if you are speaking
magnitude wise
then we must have that n1 magnitude
is equal to
[Music]
n2 magnitude is equal to
n3 magnitude but
we also know uh
but we also know that n1 square
plus n 2 square plus n 3 square
must be equal to what it must be equal
to 1
why because we know that this is the
unit outward normal
so this is actually so this represents
the square of the magnitude of that unit
outward normal so this is equal to 1
square is equal to 1
okay now this this thing
n 1 magnitude is equal to n to magnitude
is equal to n 3 magnitude
coupled with the fact that this is true
leads us to the conclusion
that
[Music]
n1 magnitude should be equal to
n2 magnitude should be equal to n3
magnitude
should be equal to what should be equal
to
1 by square root of 3 please do not put
a plus or minus sign here okay this is
not plus minus this is only plus
1 by square root of 3 okay
now because we have
such a situation you tell me how many
such special planes that are equally
inclined to the coordinate axis are
possible
you see we have two combinations here
coupled with two combinations here
coupled with two combinations here so
how many how many total combinations do
we have so we must have
eight total combinations okay so
interchanging between the plus 1 by root
3
and the minus 1 by root 3 if we take
different combinations
we'll end up with 8 different sets
of this n 1 n1 n2 and n3 and each
one of each one of those eight sets is
going to represent
a certain plane okay so the
a particular combination of this n1 into
n3 so suppose
you have n 1 equal to 1 by root 3 n 2
equal to 1 by root 3
and n 3 equal to minus 1 by root 3 that
will give rise to a certain plane
if you take n 1 equal to minus 1 by root
3 n 2 equal to 1 by root 3 and n 3 equal
to 1 by root 3 that will give rise to
a dist another separate plane so all in
all if you take the different
combinations
you will end up with eight different
planes that are equally inclined
to the three coordinate axis and if you
consider
all of them together okay the the
geometrical figure that we'll
end up with is going to look like an
octahedron
okay so that is what is the the reason
behind this behind this name that we are
calling this as octahedral stresses
so as this as the name of the topic
suggests that
when we consider the stresses
on these eight different octahedral
planes
the various stresses that are uh that
are there they are referred to as the
octet with stresses of course
now it is interesting to uh take a look
quickly
and what would be the uh what would be
the expressions
for the octahedral normal stress and the
octahedral shear stress
so what we are saying is that suppose
you consider such a plane
and you consider a generic fraction
vector on it
and you consider the t n out of it okay
please note that this tn
has nothing to do with the principle
stress itself
okay that principle direction has to do
with the coordinate axis
this time the the plane itself
is is absolutely different from those
principal planes this is the octahedral
plane
we are talking about okay so
uh so this plane uh this plane that we
are talking about that is the
octahedral plane
okay this is quite it is absolutely
different from the principal plane
now if we are on that plane and we are
considering the normal component of the
traction vector
then that will be referred to as the
octahedral normal stress
and the shear component the
corresponding shear component
of the traction vector that will be
referred to as the octahedral shear
stress so let us quickly take a look
at what the expressions shape up to be
so earlier we had we had said
that the
so first of all the octahedral normal
stress
so that is tn
and that we have already seen
the expression for that is
[Music]
in terms of the matrix representation
[Music]
it is n hat matrix transpose
multiplied with the stress matrix
multiplied with the
uh with the column matrix
[Music]
of the n hat now
uh what is this trace matrix
it is the uh it is the state of stress
which is representing the
thus the stress state referred to
the coordinate axis that we have chosen
and what is the nature of that
coordinate axis
it is specially oriented along the three
principal directions
now if we take a quick look at what we
had learnt in our earlier class
you see that the state of stress it
shapes up
in this fashion shapes up in this
fashion
so all the only the diagonal elements
are non-zero
uh here and all the off diagonal
elements are zero
so what we are going to have here is
this
[Music]
n1 n2 n3 this is a row matrix because of
this transpose here
and the stress stress matrix
it is sigma 1 here
sigma 2 here and sigma 3 here
everything else is 0.
and finally for the column matrix
of the n hat we have n one into an m3
like this
now if we if we if we carry out the
calculation
what we'll find is this is
sigma 1 times n1 square
plus sigma 2 and
2 square plus sigma
3 and 3 square
but in the previous slide we have
already seen
that the that each one of these
magnitudes of n1 n2 and n3 is 1 by
square root of 3
which means that this one
this n1 square is nothing but 1 by 3 n2
squared is 1 by 3
and n3 squared is 1 by 3 so overall what
we have
is this thing
[Music]
so we can write here that since
n one magnitude is equal to n to
magnitude
is equal to n three magnitude is equal
to
one by square root of three
now uh you must realize
a very important fact here
this combination sigma 1 plus sigma 2
plus sigma 3
it is basically coming so these are the
diagonal elements of this stress state
so because we have uh we have
uh referred our our uh our coordinate
axis
or we are referring to a coordinate axis
the set of coordinate axes which are
oriented along the principal directions
that is why the state of stress has
shaped up like this
but suppose suppose we had we had chosen
a different stress state
then surely the off diagonal elements
would have been non-zero
in general but even then
whatever the value of the diagonal
elements individually might be
what is the if you uh if you remember
what would be the combination of sigma 1
1
plus sigma 2 to plus sigma 3 3 so i want
you to remember what we had discussed
a couple of classes earlier
[Music]
so you see here the i1 was one of the
stress
in variance and here we had seen that it
was sigma 1 1 plus sigma 2 2 plus sigma
3
3 in general and what we had said was
that
each of these values may vary separately
as we keep on changing our choice of the
coordinate axis
but the entire combination in which it
appears
in this i1 that value does not change
for a given state of stress
but a given physical state of stress so
if we come back to this slide that we
are talking about now
here also you have seen that we have
only made a choice
of our coordinate axis to be referred to
the principal directions
but and and and these values may come up
to be whatever
they need to be but overall this
particular combination is nothing but
the first
stress in variant only so we must be
[Music]
able to write in the next step
as 1 by 3 i1 so you note
that the octahedral normal stress that
is the tn
component referred specially to a plane
which is inclined equally to the
three coordinate axis
which in turn are referred to which are
oriented along the principal directions
is such
that this is nothing but one of the
stress ingredients
this is an extremely extremely important
fact okay so
so please note it down
next what about the octahedral shear
stress
[Music]
so
well the octahedral shear stress
we can think of it like this
we've already seen the expression of it
in terms of the traction vector itself
so the magnitude of that square minus
the tn
all right so
you note that in this particular case
our t vector is
sigma if we write the cauchy's formula
it is sigma dot n hat
and this one will be in matrix
representation what
we can use the symmetricity of the
stress tensor and
this will be simply sigma 1
sigma 2 sigma 3 here
rest of it is 0.
n1 n2 and 3
so
this is going to be what sigma 1
n1 sigma 2
n2 sigma 3
and 3 and shaped up like a column matrix
[Music]
and this makes sense that it should be a
column matrix
because you see that this here is a
traction vector
so the equivalent matrix representation
i can write it like this
it makes more sense to write everything
in terms of the equivalent matrix
representation
so
so the traction vector must have three
components and because it is a column
matrix we choose to write
and because it is a vector we choose to
write it like a column matrix
so it must have three components and
these are the three components
so what we are going to say here is that
the t1 is equal to
sigma 1 n1 the t2
is equal to sigma 2 n2
and the t3 is equal to sigma
3 n3
all right so if we if we substitute
the these things here back here
we can actually proceed with finding the
expression for the ts
so going to the next slide we write this
formula again
the ts square is equal to
[Music]
the vector magnitude square minus t
n square
now you note that this is nothing but t
1 square
plus t 2 plus t3 square
[Music]
let me clean that up a little bit
[Music]
okay so this is t1 square plus t2
square plus t3 square is the t vector
magnitude square
and the tn is nothing but we have
already seen that to be
one by three
sigma 1 plus sigma 2
plus sigma 3
so
this whole thing square
and the t1 from the previous slide if we
just glance
quickly the t1 the t2 and t3 are given
by these expressions so coming back here
these are sigma 1
n1 sigma 1 n1
sigma 2 n2 sigma 3 m3 so
square of that plus
[Music]
sigma 2 n2
square plus sigma 3
m3 square minus
one by nine if i keep all these things
inside
it becomes like that now you also note
that this
uh n1 square is
is also the we have this thing to be
true
that n1 square is
uh so n one squared is actually one by
three
so i need to make a correction here
so this is one by three
and this is
sigma 1 square
plus sigma 2
square plus sigma
3 square
all right
[Music]
minus 1 by 9
sigma 1 plus sigma 2 plus sigma 3
square so
if we continue doing the algebra
[Music]
so what we'll obtain is 1 by 9 here
and you get a 3 here so that is
3
[Music]
sigma 1 um
whole square plus
3 sigma 2 whole square
plus 3 sigma 3
whole square minus
sigma 1 whole square
minus sigma 2 whole square
minus sigma 3 whole square
and then the
the combinations minus 2
sigma
this subscript should not be here
the sigma 1 sigma 2 combination
the sigma 2 sigma
sigma 3 combination and the sigma
3 sigma one combination
so
[Music]
this thing is going to be
so you understand that this is three
sigma one square minus
1 sigma 1 square so that is twice sigma
1 square
so
[Music]
what i would like to do is i i would
like to make this
these things so after i've made the
the the subtraction after i've done the
subtraction i'll make
i'd like to take the perfect square of
that
i'd like to write this as i'm skipping a
step here
i hope you don't mind uh
this thing and
uh of course that entire thing would
come
with with a 2 in front
so maybe i should rewrite this
[Music]
to sigma 1 that's sigma
2 plus sigma 3
whole square so now we have
some extra sigma 1 sigma 2 combination
so that have to be subtracted
and because there's a 2 in front so what
you need to do is you
need to take a minus 4 sigma 1 sigma 2
minus 4 sigma 2 sigma 3 and minus 4
sigma 3 sigma
1 but these twos are already present
so what we need to write this overall
so i'm basically skipping two steps here
is
6 sigma 1 sigma 2
minus 6 sigma 2
sigma 3 minus 6
sigma 3 sigma 1
[Music]
now uh if i continue in the in the next
slide
what i would like to get at is that you
see this combination is our familiar
first stress invariant
and what about this sigma 1 sigma 2
sigma 2 sigma 3
and the sigma 3 sigma 1 so if you
quickly look back
at the slide containing the the stress
invariance
will recognize a familiar form so you
see here
the second stress invariant i do here
from an earlier slide
this is basically sigma 1 1 sigma 2 2
minus sigma 1 2 square but in the
in the in the case that we are currently
doing the sigma 1 2 square
is not there because the off diagonal
terms are 0
so it is basically sigma 1 1 sigma 2 2
sigma 2 to sigma 3 3 and sigma 3
sigma 1 1 so if we come back
if you come back to this thing you'll
see that this sigma 1 1 sigma 2
2 sorry sigma 1 sigma 2 sigma 2 sigma 3
and sigma 3 sigma 1
that particular combination is nothing
but the uh
but the i2 itself
so going to the next slide what we'll
have is
the s square is equal to
the glass counts back here so 1 by 9 is
present in front
so this is 2 into
i1 square minus this is 6 into i2
so the magnitude of ts
that will be what
so
i would like to take this two also
outside so what i will do is
i can write this in one step as square
root of 2 by 3
and within bracket i will have i 1
square
minus 3 i 2
the square root of that okay please note
that here i am writing
this as the magnitude the ts
magnitude in fact you can put this as a
magnitude also
all right so this is this expression is
the
octahedral normal shear octahedral shear
stress
component and earlier what we had found
out
the where the we had found out the octet
normal stress so that was 1 by 3 i1 and
the octahedral shear stress
that comes out as square root of 2 by 3
i1 squared minus 3 i2
but you note that the special thing
going on here
is that both the tn as well as the ts
they come out in terms of the stress in
variance
okay so both
[Music]
octahedral
normal and
shear stresses
are expressed
in terms of
stress imbalance
[Music]
all right so um
with this we are going to end this part
of the lecture
and and in the next part of the lecture
we are again going to talk about certain
other
types of parts of the stress tensor and
that's going to be very very interesting
and useful
all right thank you very much